growing up my favorite thing my mother
ever made was lemon meringue pie
I'd watch her squeeze fresh lemons beat
egg whites into a fluffy cloud and place
it in the fridge where I'd wait hours
for it to chill before I could eat this
lemon gooey goodness as much as I
enjoyed eating it my mother enjoyed
baking it because she was doing
something her mother did for her my mom
comes from a large family that didn't
have much growing up because some black
families historically didn't have
monetary valuables to pass down my
grandmother like most passed down her
recipes so once a year my grandmother
would make all seven of her children
whatever dessert they asked for my
mother always asked for lemon meringue
pie and it was the first pie she ever
learned to bake then one fateful day
when I was in high school just like
always she squeezed the lemons made in
the cloud and placed it in the fridge
but instead of pie we got soup my mom
was devastated but I wasn't gonna let it
go to waste
I literally drink it she tried the
recipe again but just more soup till
this day we still don't know what went
wrong so here's my problem I want to be
able to pass this recipe down to my kids
my niece's my nephews so I've asked my
good friend IO to help me fix this
recipe Infantino sexy yeah I've sent you
over how my mom's made it she literally
like put it out on index cards what do
you think we can do to fix it I have a
few ideas first of all I love the recipe
so for all schools all dirty generations
yeah the one thing I notice is there's
no cornstarch and I feel like usually
people use cornstarch to make it like
foolproof you know what I mean
love the idea but uh grandmama Clara
Davis would never Clara baby yes miss
Clara Dave okay well we wish I were
spitting to miss Clara Davis let's go
get the ingredients and then we'll
figure it out
all right sounds good
[Music]
first thing I think we should do is
focus on the feelings since you said
that's the problem
here yeah the recipe does say eight
lemons no offence the moment clear days
is eight is a lot of limits especially
because our limits are a little more
aggressive what they probably had back
in the day so I think we should do six
lemons okay I think the six lemons
instead of eight will help it's it can
reduce the soup eNOS of it so while
you're busy on that I am gonna separate
the yolks from the whites because you
need the yolks for the filling and I
need the whites for my meringue and
we're gonna go for me roll it first yeah
get it all juicy good I mean like I said
this an aggressive limit so I don't
think it would hurt you
so I crack the eggs actually into my
hand and then I just kind of open my
finger then let the whites fall through
I know people do the egg shell thing but
that's usually where I end up cracking
the yolk so I just kind of let the
weight fall through help it out a little
bit I have literally never seen that in
my life you can never be my food chef
I'll kill you this is
pranks eight eggs and you were still
massaging these lemons requires delicacy
you know on the recipe you didn't say
love but you need to make it with love I
feel like there Davis will be day
clear days also didn't have these nails
we'll start there how many people are in
I know if it's a big family how many of
them is my mom is the youngest of seven
yeah clear day that's a busy you know
it's funny when you originally told me
about this recipe uh-huh
I was so shocked because I don't I've
never had lemon meringue pie really yeah
it's just so not my like cultural
experience it's not my black experience
very much like people have that know
when I mentioned in my mom's shoes I
kids delicious I was like well since
we're you gonna tell me where you gonna
make know my mom it's my grandma yes
Janey Bell makes the pie it is a black
grandmother thing and a great thing
about this I noticed it makes - it does
that's how you know she had a bunch of
kids mm-hmm all right so we're gonna
clean up is one thing my mother always
taught me clearly find yourself yes as
you cook
right boo-boo [ __ ] make sense all right
so we have everything we have our
condensed milk we have our eggs we have
our cup and a half of lemon juice so I'm
gonna mix the condensed milk and do you
want to whisk yeah you got the wrist
action first if typically what you would
do is temper in the eggs but a condensed
milk makes this super easy we do
literally none of that just get in there
oh this is so much okay so I am not in
love with your whisking techniques okay
you pour the thin wire with do you love
my pouring technique how do you yes yes
fine it'll do very liquidy yeah I smell
it you smell the lemon smell it okay I
think we have incorporated enough pour
it in the center she used her like
bounces back and forth to even them out
all right I think that's all I think
that's all she's gonna give us you've
had way too much fun yeah all right
what's next
Oh so next we're gonna make the meringue
she's gonna wipe it I was shot so hard
to go
[Laughter]
so now we're gonna make our topping
we're gonna make the meringue I'm gonna
add a little bit of cream of tartar cuz
it'll help it stabilize it makes it a
little more foolproof for us
well we allow that I'll allow it okay so
we're gonna do that all right the reason
we let them sit out here is because we
need them to come up to like room
temperature Oh cuz it helps it come
together and whip easier and they're
gonna be glossy shiny and just perfect
so we're gonna add in our egg whites
you're gonna start seeing it form up cuz
the arrow start to change the color so
is also being translucent like this -
like a beautiful white meringue okay so
I think it's ready for us to add our
cream of tartar we're actually just
adding a teaspoon so not a whole lot
it's not gonna make a lot of difference
in the flavor but again it'll help
stabilize it okay okay so I think we're
about ready to add the sugar you see how
fluffy it is mm-hmm I'm just gonna add a
little bit of sugar at a time and I
believe the recipe says one teaspoon per
egg so we're gonna follow Mom through
the PIA give me a little sprinkle
oh I think we're they they look like
what you remember yes good it really
still fits like it hmm
I mean how much do you trust your mom's
recipe I mean you added something called
tartar all right so after you gotten to
this point what did your mom do she
literally just like dollop them on and
then a circle okay well I will let you
do it make it mama proud
all righty something like that I don't
it doesn't have to be perfect it's not
gonna be maybe you could take a lie and
then smooth it around okay we'll try
that I think that would be a lot easier
than the individual what I'm doing I
think I think they're fancy okay so the
recipe I noticed did not have a time nor
temperature
they just said cook into this brown
which totally understand my grandma's
all about like it just feels right when
it looks right okay well I haven't made
this 200 times Grand Moff I need like
yeah Pacific's so what do you think she
generally bakes at like 375 and again
just until it rounds 375 feels a little
high okay I think it'll make you brown
fast and it won't sit which is what
we're trying to fix so I think we drop
that down just a tad so let's do 350
okay and then we'll just keep a eye on
the other Browns are we gonna think - or
- I love you have to make it with love I
don't see where yelling at me it smells
good and they look really nice yeah so
at 350 this only took us about 15
minutes yeah so we need to let it sit
for an hour okay and then what if your
mom usually do she pretty much puts it
in the fridge see this is one of those
black family recipe things because
nowhere on that recipe card that if they
put it in the fridge she definitely I
know for sure she puts it in the fridge
so was it like three episodes of Rugrats
long or like let's chill it now for
about three hours which is like a
marathon of regrets and after that we'll
put it on we'll eat it let's go for it
all right she definitely did not say
we're on the right track because it's
not as soupy as when she had made it so
much is happening on this plate like the
true struggle okay hmm I will say the
lemon
we're spot on but it just doesn't taste
as sweet as I remember if thing is
limiting right yeah so we'll regroup and
we'll try this again tomorrow
Oh maybe tomorrow I can redeem myself
because I feel like I'm like on the
baking Bachelor like I didn't get a rose
tonight was not my night I feel I have
faith tomorrow we will make this happen
we have to we have no you're not
embarrass me I have these streets now we
have a group we have slept
we have slept on this I think the name
of the game today is reduced the Jews we
didn't measure the lemon juice we were
just like yeah so today I definitely
think we'll measure it will go about
half a cup of lemon juice per pie so one
cup total but you did say it was good
eliminate the best way to get the flavor
without all the juice is to this ooh
yeah have your assistant lemon now I
just so basically basically you're gonna
take this the microplane and you're just
gonna put it against the flesh you're
not gonna push it down to our cuz you
don't want the white part don't just
want those lovely little lemon shavings
from the top all righty
okay so I'm gonna let you do this okay
and you just lightly press it yeah if
I'm 15 turn it cuz you don't want to get
in too far yeah okay I think if that's
the old girl enough she's oh did I she's
been through a lot you can start with a
new one huh and I'm actually gonna juice
this on why you do that because game
where it makes the dream it's a love my
mother always puts on gospel music when
she's cooking my grandmother did to see
Jenny cooks with the Lord
all right every fan in the kitchen if
you got time to lean you got time to
clean
oh and you're not doing anything so
let's clean up and we'll start mixing
our filling operation reduce the juices
done since you said you wanted a little
bit sweeter yes it is I think we should
add a little more sugar always down for
more sugar so the cornstarch is no no
but sugar you're like yeah okay okay so
we're gonna make the filling just like
we did last time we have our condensed
milk we have our eggs our sugar our two
tablespoons of lemon zest and our cup of
lemon juice
Wow I think we can go ahead and make our
meringue we did this right yesterday we
did do something right so we're gonna
add our egg whites our tartar and our
sugar so then we just do it so we're we
are not doing this god that's me good
that's me still going gonna be a while
work it out
good nice I think we're there so I'm
gonna let you go ahead and do your thing
with the decorating maybe today we can
give her a little more body
she got curves see see see th I see see
you know what the kids yesterday I think
we cooked it for about 15 minutes
yeah she wasn't fit at all today I think
we should go a little bit longer so I
also think we should reduce the
temperature that way we can keep it from
getting too Brown too fast but we can
also give the feeling a little more time
to cooking in the love all right I think
we did it this time I think we need to
give them their best shot at life though
this time I think we should add about
two hours to the chill time so 5 hours
this time okay that gives us enough time
to like watch the whole girlfriends
boxset I'm a fan we are gonna make this
happen because yeah three days things
for pie I'm not coming over here a third
time you won't have the fire
so this is our second attempt dumbness
twice now with love we refuse to do it a
third time
alright I'm gonna let you cut into it
cuz my heart can't take it I'm ready
let's go for it I feel like there's more
stressful than it should be it is I told
you if I had the baking Bachelor are we
getting a rose we in the final rose girl
you're making me nervous
I think we did I think we did this was
mine
okay let's taste I'm gonna say and I ate
a hole yesterday that it we did it is
everything this is good I really like
this cuz it's like my mom's but we swish
it up a bit so I kind of made it my own
it has like the perfect balance of sweet
women I'm a fan I think if we go through
generations the most important part for
all of us is like getting a little bit
better where there's your pie whether
it's like your quality of life like
we're all trying to do just a little bit
better than the generation before us
so this pie is like a perfect
representation of this so you like the
threat feed yes this is it cuz I think
we we've nailed it so I actually type
this up for you so you can have it but
there's no way you were gonna remember
this
[Music]
you